how to clean a Kalashnikov that's one
skill that Pavel learned during a month
of boot camp he says he never wanted to
become a soldier but now here he is
fighting a war for a month and a half
now Pavel has been deployed in eastern
Ukraine with the dumb boss ballinteer
battalion I'm fighting so that Ukraine
can be free again to liberate it from
the separatists in the hands can
Burnett's from the Russians and the
Chechens we don't need them here John
he's been granted 24 hours to rest and
recuperate here in Papa's not a village
near Luhansk then it's back into combat
Pavel comes from Western Ukraine
hundreds of volunteers like him have
joined this unit they don't speak much
about their operations around pump Ozma
and elsewhere and when they do the words
only hint at what they've experienced no
kalisto Cilic Rasheeda we were ordered
to attack separatists checkpoints and
believed we'd be facing only a few
rebels look at them with a seal but
there were 10 times more of them than we
expected so we had to pull back you
establish license to be spit order for
these and the pause from fighting was
brief last night the battalion saw heavy
combat once again